so uh I know so many of you
I'm trying to see who I don't know
anyway uh a
h
um
we are a collaborative Center for
research University science and we were
we were founded the as many years ago at
this point in 2012 was a large brand
from Simon's Foundation it was also kind
enough to renew our Center so we will be
going strong for another 15 years at
least hopefully more
and um
organizers
who are you
interest yourselves the God is one of
them
where is he
okay
so I want to go through a few Logistics
um
there are lockers on the side of the
building which you can use Omid is the
videographer and you know whenever
there's a problem you sort of slide them
down he's very attentive so he knows
um and I want to thank Elizabeth
Sport Shop and it's in charge for all
the logistics
[Music]
and we will have a reception at the end
of the day today so it's also customary
the first week thank you very much and I
think that the next option is coming in
are you going to have another uh we have
a hierarchy
[Laughter]
assumptions for photography as you know
this is part of their meta complexity
program that is ending with this
Workshop and uh I'm really excited to
the whole year we have a fantastic
schedule of talks all that intersection
of cryptography complexity and uh
basically ever since I started with
cryptography I kind of felt that right
now it's a golden area of work between
cryptography complexity but right now I
feel it even more there's been so many
like breakthroughs in the last
five years and we're gonna hear about
these results here so
are here
all right sorry
who's going to tell us about uh one of
the biggest strict results in the in the
last few years in particular about how
to construct based on standard
assumptions so I'm very excited here
objectives
thanks everyone for coming this morning
so yeah so this is going to be a general
uh talk on cryptographic proofs but the
primary focus is going to be on succinct
proofs and I'll try to set up stage for
many of the talks that will happen later
today and some of them tomorrow
okay so allow me to indulge let's talk
about proofs in general right so for
most of us our first uh you know memory
approves is mathematical proofs where
there is a prover who is trying to prove
some statement to a verifier and usually
such a proof you know consists of a
bunch of lines and each line follows uh
via some rules or actions and the nice
thing is that the proof can be just sent
by a single message to the verifier who
can then decide to accept or reject and
such proofs have existed long before any
of us were born
in computer science we take a
computational
computational lens to prove uh so the
verifier is a polynomial time machine
and if we think about the class NP then
essentially says that for any two
statement there is an accepting proof
namely the NP witness that the prover
can send to the verifier who can then
decide to accept a reject and there is a
second property which is soundness which
basically says that if the statement is
false then any proof will be rejected
right any improved sent by the proofer
so this ladder property is what really
speaks to the core appeal of proofs
which is that I don't really have to you
know take people's assertions on on
Fifth I can instead ask them to prove it
to me right and to utilize this uh Power
of proofs in the real world
cryptographic proofs ask for much much
more so two seemingly Fantastical
properties which seem impossible to
First at realize to realize that first
but nevertheless can be achieved and I'm
going to talk about both of these
properties one by one
um so let me take an example so suppose
approver wants to prove to a verifier
that a huge graph is three colorable and
since this is an NP statement the
approver can simply write down the
entire coloring of the graph and send it
to the verifier
but this is a very large proof right the
witness here can be very very large and
what we ask is if it if it is possible
to somehow shrink uh this uh this
witness into a very very small proof
that can still convince the verifier so
this is the property of succinctness
which basically says that the proof
should both be very short to communicate
and very very fast to verifier much much
smaller than the witness size
and in this setting where the proverb
just sends a single message to the
verifier these are referred to as
succinct non-interactive arguments so
succinct because the proof is short
non-interactive because it's one message
an argument because the soundness
guarantees only against polynomial time
approvals so computational soundness
and these groups have lots of
applications the general idea is that
they allow us to do verifiable
delegation of computation namely a weak
computational device can offload some
heavy work let's say training some
neural network to a Cloud Server and
then ask the the Cloud Server to
actually provide a proof of correct
computation and because the proof is
short and easy to verify the pro the
verifier can quickly check the answer
okay so that's the first property the
second property of cryptographic proofs
that we care about is where the prover
does not even want to reveal let's say
the coloring of the graph to the
verifier instead it wants to send a
proof that hides the witness from the
verifier and this is called the zero
knowledge something we have studied for
many years essentially says that a proof
can convince a verifier that a statement
is true without revealing why it is true
again in the non-interactive setting we
refer to as it does non-interactive zero
knowledge
and non-interactive zero knowledge is
very useful for privacy applications so
here is a flagship application these
days let's say I have a blockchain which
is essentially a sequence of
transactions ordered in blocks and I
want to hide everything about the
blockchains I want to hide all the
transactions the account balances and
everything
um so how could I go about doing this so
let's say I have a way of encrypting
everything but now the problem is that
how do I verify that a transaction is
valid right so maybe somebody's account
balance is actually zero but they want
to try and do a transaction which is
exceeds their account balance so using
uh zero knowledge proofs we can solve
this dilemma by just asking the the
person connecting the transaction to
prove that they have sufficient balance
in their account and this is a general
idea of basically forcing honest
behavior on participants while
preserving privacy of data
and for this reason uh proofs have lots
of replications in the real world over
the last uh you know several years
perhaps we most know about the
applications to blockchains many
companies using the these group systems
but even you know traditional things
like signature schemes have uh or
perhaps the most widely used signature
schemes have their roots in interactive
groups
um groups also have strong connections
to Theory so we know of you know strong
connections to complexity Theory like
PCP theorem ipcl2p space and connections
to other areas as well which I think
some of these things will be covered
later on in the in this Workshop
um some other connections which are
maybe Sub sub cases of connections to
complexity Theory so we will probably
hear about some connections to uh meta
complexity maybe tomorrow or day after
um and also connections to the
randomization as well these are pretty
old connections but some newer
connections have been established which
are kind of exciting
okay so now having said all of this
um let me ask the basic question do
cryptographic books exist with these
properties and if I if I allow for
interaction between the prover and the
verifier namely that they can exchange a
lot of messages with each other the
answer is uh yes and we have known this
for many years in fact we can build
interactive proofs uh both with zero
knowledge and succinctness properties
from Fairly weak assumptions
um
so for this talk the main focus is going
to be on interact cryptographic proofs
that are non-interactive
and in this particular scenario for the
case of nizzix the answer is again yes
something that we have known for a while
although a lot of problems has happened
recently and for snugs the answer is a
bit complicated so I'm going to
elaborate on this part uh primarily for
the rest of the talk and again just to
mention even though the answer for
nizzix was yes and was known for many
years a lot of progress has happened in
in improving our understanding of this
of this field in the recent years
so this talk I want to survey some of
the recent research in the case of
Snorks and along the way I'll also
establish connections how this line of
research also has implications to
physics
let me now formally Define something
non-interactive arguments so let's say
there is a prover that wants to prove
that the output of some deterministic or
non-deterministic computation is is one
and we want the following properties
from such a proof so first of all I will
I'm going to allow The Proven verifier
to actually share some common reference
string that has been sampled in advance
honestly and given to both the approval
and verifier
um and now in this model I want uh First
of and foremost I think this which says
that the proof size the verification
time and CRS size ideally all of these
things should be very small much much
smaller than T where T is the time of
computation
and soundness basically as before just
says that if the statement is false
namely the output is not equal to 1 then
the proof should be rejected
how do we build snacks how can we build
snarks what do we know in this area
so turns out we know a lot you know this
is something that people have been
studying for uh many years I'm out of
space here on the slide
um
so incredible line of research and some
of these results actually can even build
snacks for NP so really you know what we
would like
um have tremendous real world impacts
something that I've already conveyed
um the main issue is that the results
that do actually achieve snacks for NP
and in fact even other results uh
security wise they are lacking so the
main issue is that these results either
achieve heuristic Security in idolized
models or rely on what are called
non-falsifiable assumptions not going to
elaborate uh right now what non-fossible
falsifiable assumptions mean but just
very briefly uh just think of them as
assumptions where it's not efficient to
verify if somebody has actually found a
break for the assumptions
okay so can we then build snots from
actual standard assumptions
um
so this is what has happened in the last
few years so until 2019 we really didn't
know anything in this space
um
and then 2019 onwards uh things started
to change uh starting from the work of
kalai panath and yang who gave a
construction for snots for some classes
of languages which I'll mention in a
moment from not from falsifiable but
still non-standard assumptions and then
things started exploding in 2021 where
many constructions were proposed uh and
this is already only continuing in the
last two years or so
so all of these results Focus not on NP
but on either deterministic computations
or some subclasses up in the
um and when I say standard assumptions I
really mean assumptions like uh you know
that we love in cryptography like
learning with errors standard
assumptions over bilingual Maps uh
diffie-hellman assumptions and so on
another thing to note is that I've
ignored here some lines of research
which maybe will be covered later in the
in the workshop things like privately
verifiable snacks where we don't
actually uh require that anyone can
verify a proof but rather only
designated verifiers can verify groups
okay so now let me get into technical
details of how uh you know some
some of these Works uh actually achieve
these results
okay so let's start with a general
recipe for snogs and this recipe by the
way is not limited to these works this
is actually true for pretty much all
snack instructions that we know in the
literature even the Practical
constructions that are
um that are used in the real world so
very very simplified view of things so
we start with the proofs in some Oracle
models so think of for example pcps
where the approver you know establishes
some giant Oracle which is not counted
in the communication and the proof size
we only think about the proof size as
the the verified queries to these
oracles
then we try to somehow you know
transform these Oracle model proofs to
succinct interactive groups where
there are there are no more oracles and
The Proven verifi are allowed to
interact with each other exchange
multiple messages
and then we try to compress them into a
single message proof
so the first step involves building some
cryptographic compiler to get rid of the
oracles and the second step is round
compression step which requires
basically collapsing all the rounds of
the protocol into a single message
so I'm going to focus on the second part
uh here for the rest of the talk uh
which is where these two lines of
research and the applied the applied
results and the theory results they
diverge uh primarily in the wrong
compression step so
yeah
you should think of yeah
alien style proofs where you use some
kind of commitment scheme maybe to
commit to the big speed yeah
okay no so what I'm saying is think of
Oracle as a PCP yes
okay so let's talk about wrong
compression of interactive proofs so we
want to start with some proof which is
interactive and end up with a
non-interactive proof and ideally we
would like this transformation to
preserve the properties of the
interactive proofs namely if you start
with a proof that is succinct we end up
with a snorg and if we start with a
proof which is zero knowledge we end up
with a music
and there is one transform that we have
studied for many years which actually
satisfies these properties namely the
fiercemi transform
so this transform basically says the
following if you start with some
interactive truth in this case just a
three round proof but it could be
multiple rounds where the verifiers
messages are just random strings
um then we can actually transform it
into a non-infective proof by just
Computing the verifier challenges using
a hash function
and the fear shimmy transform says that
if we model this hash function as some
idle object a random Oracle then this
resulting protocol is actually still
secure in the sense that soundness of
the underlying protocol the interactive
protocol is guaranteed in the
non-interactive setting as well
so what do we know about the security of
the hme transform
so heuristically this is secure you know
in the sense that we just imagine that
the hash function behaves like a random
function and then you know we can say
that okay this is hopefully uh hopefully
secure but in theory we know that this
is not a secure transform in the sense
that people have shown starting from uh
you know the work of Barack and then
Shafi and Yael people have shown that
there exists protocols uh for which
there is no way to come up with a secure
hash function such that the resulting
you know the the final non-interactive
protocol will actually be secure or will
be sound
so this is where basically things have
changed in the last several years uh
which is trying to circumvent uh these
negative results how to actually uh you
know uh how to securely instantiate the
future may transform uh using standard
assumptions or how to avoid these
impossible to results
so the idea is essentially the following
I'm simplifying things but
um let me just let me just State what
are the crucial steps involved in trying
to get results in the standard in the
standard model
so the first step is to avoid these
impossibility results by focusing on a
subclass of interactive proofs namely
proofs which are statistically sound
so that is unbounded time through work
and also not cheat
and then we in the second step we build
the hash functions that essentially
avoid the bad challenges which might
allow a cheating prover to prove false
statements
so if you think about statistically
sound proofs we have the guarantee that
for every uh you know first message
let's say Alpha here there are only some
small number of uh you know verified
challenges for which there exist
accepting third messages so the idea
then is to build hash functions that can
somehow avoid these bad challenges and
these are what are called correlation
interactable hash functions
in the last five years this idea of
compiling a subclass of interactive
proofs into non-interactive proofs using
correlation interactable hash has found
lots and lots of applications so this is
where uh the research on snogs and
physics have uh you know uh they they
join in the sense that using this
Paradigm not only have we managed to
build snarks for uh deterministic
computations and other subclasses of NP
but also nifix you know establish
hardness results for ppad build and
build other objects as well for example
verifiable delay functions and even
counter examples to parallel composition
of zero knowledge groups okay so very
very successful line of research
okay so what I want to focus on is uh
how to use this idea of correlation
interactability uh to build snarks and
also just comment a little bit on how it
also applies to musics
so let's actually start with the letter
so if we want to use this idea to build
nysics then what we want to do is start
from a interactive proof which is
statistically sound and has zero
knowledge property and then build some
kind of correlation intractable hash
functions which can avoid the bad
challenges in that particular proof
interactive proof it turns out that you
know in this in the case of zero
knowledge the first step which is
building an interactive proof this is
easy this is something we have known for
many years so really the the hard part
is actually in building correlation
intractable hash
so how do we build correlation
interactable hash this is essentially
what we now know for uh from many works
in the last four or five years we know
actually correlation interactable hash
for some kinds of relations which I'm
not going to dive into right now uh from
both standard lattice assumptions and
also from Standard Group assumptions and
this is going to be the focus of the
next stock so I'm not going to get into
this now
what I do want to talk about is how this
General Paradigm can be used for
building snarks so here we want to start
from interactive proofs which are
succinct and then you know apply this
correlation intractable hash framework
to that
so here the pressure point uh actually
already shows up in the first step which
is actually building uh assessing proofs
which are statistically sound so let's
just assume that we have correlation in
fact double hash uh for whatever
relations we need and we care about
let's just focus on the first step which
is actually building succinct
interactive proofs which which have
statistical foundness
so the main reason why this step turns
out to be challenging is because of this
simple barrier uh barrier which is we
want uh interactive proofs both uh you
know both with low communication and
statistical soundness and this is
something that you know we know for some
subclass of computations like bounded
depth or bounded space deterministic
computations but beyond that uh you know
they are unlikely to exist
and this creates uh you know the main
barrier in trying to apply this General
methodology to build snogs for uh for
let's say P or other subclasses of MP
so here is the the blueprint for trying
to overcome this barrier that I'm going
to elaborate in the next few minutes
so first of all I'm going to change the
problem statement a little bit instead
of talking about let's say deterministic
computations I'm going to talk about a
particular class of languages called
batch NP and I'm going to explain in a
moment what that means so we are going
to first shift our Focus to building
snots for batch MP
and for this class of language I'm going
to introduce a new soundness notion
which will help us in overcoming this
statistical soundness barrier so it will
help us in in transforming interactive
proofs for batch NP using the
correlation interactable hash framework
to build snacks for batch
so then once we have this in place then
I'm going to show you that batch NP
proofs or proofs for batch NP are sort
of complete in the sense that once you
have snot for bash NP you can actually
build snogs for determinister
computations okay so this is the second
idea
and then the third question remaining
one is how do we actually build these
interactive assessing proofs for batch
NP and this is the last one the last
piece of the puzzle so once you have all
of these ideas together you can you can
obtain snacks for all the domestic
computations and as a bonus you get
snots for batch entry right so this is
the blueprint
okay so let's talk about uh snacks for
batch NP first
so so the problem statement is as
follows so the prover now instead of
proving one statement to the verify it
has let's say capital T statements and
it wants to prove that all of them are
true so this is a conjunction over T
statements tnp statements and the key
requirement is that the proof size
should be small in the sense that it
should not grow with the number of
statements right but it is allowed to
grow let's say with the size of a single
witness so it's really amortization
right that I can prove capital T
statements by only paying in the you
know the the size of one witness that's
it
this this notion of batch and P has
between studied before in the context of
you know batching in the context of
signatures in the context of interactive
proofs and it has lots of applications
in fact uh perhaps one of the most
common applications of snods in
blockchains can which is Roll-Ups can be
captured by this ID of batch entry
so now let's go towards uh identifying
the right notion of soundness for uh for
batch NP
so how do we build snacks for batch NP
so we have the following options I'm
just reiterating some of the points from
earlier so one option would be to go
towards succinct interactive proofs for
batch NP uh where proof means
statistically sound
so we know that if we have statistical
soundness it is friendly to the Future
me Paradigm using the correlation
interactivity hash framework but the
problem is we don't know how to build uh
we don't know any constructions of
succinct interactive groups with
statistical soundness for batch NP
and the alternative would be to go
towards computationally sound uh
interactive proofs for batch NP and here
we do know such proofs that they exist
in fact even for NP yeah so we do know
how to build system proofs for batch and
pay um like using the IP equals b space
um so what would happen I mean that's
not an efficient prover in any sense
yeah
I mean anything for your
yeah I mean inefficient Proverbs
um I'm not sure I haven't really thought
about uh you know what uh yeah what that
would mean in this setting but um
if you have an argument where the honest
poor is inefficient and we're talking
about sounds for efficient proofers yeah
okay so yes in the case of succinct
interactive Arguments for batch and we
we do have uh you know candidates Kelly
and Samuel gives us such Arguments for
all of NP in fact forget batch NP uh the
problem is that uh you know Killian's
protocol uh is uh it's not quite
instantiable securely and this is
something we know from recent works
So to avoid this conundrum the idea that
I'm going to produce uh sorry that I'm
going to describe basically it tries to
interpolate between statistical
soundness and computational soundness
and again for cryptographers here the
notion should be very intuitive so
the idea is to use a notion of somewhere
statistical soundness
and the idea is very simple so
so we are in the setting where the
approver is trying to prove capital T
statements to the verifier right that
all of them are true and what we require
is that instead of insisting statistical
soundness for all of the capital T
positions we are only going to require
that there is a position I where this
position I is hidden somehow in the CRS
the CRS encodes I and it hides I and we
are going to require that at this
position I a cheating crew or even
unbounded shooting crew work cannot
prove a false statement for the other
positions I don't care
uh no I mean the idea is yeah it will
work for more rounds yeah
I mean I'm just using pictorial I'm
always talking about three rounds here
but yeah it's not important yeah
location yes so I'm only going to
require that at a particular location I
which is unknown to the approver you
know it's embedded in the CRS and hidden
at that particular location even an
unbounded time prover cannot prove a
false statement right for the other
locations I I really don't care
the main point is that as location I I
have friends
right okay so a few remarks so first of
all you know if you think about uh the
communication of the proof right this
notion sort of makes sense because
because the proof is allowed to be as
large as a one witness right I can hope
for uh statistical soundness for you
know one of the instances right so in
that sense it you know it's a it's
compatible with the batch NP
and now why is it useful in the context
of uh the correlation intractability
hash framework the reason is very simple
so suppose the statement this
conjunction is false right so what that
means is that there is at least one
index I such that x i is false
right and that's all I care about right
because now if I start with an
interactive proof where I have
statistical soundness for uh you know
that location for x i right where I
managed to you know ensure that
statistical soundness holds for the ith
index then I know that I have
statistical soundness for x i right and
therefore you know when I try to this
statistical soundness for just x i is
all I need right in order to actually do
the round collapsing using correlation
interactivity so are you thinking about
the proven as computationally bounded
here
I mean in the final one it is obviously
computationally bounded yeah so the crew
cannot distinguish uh what x i is and
what i is
so that I'm allowed actually right so
I'm not actually aiming for a sickness
like NP where the proof should be
smaller than one witness I'm allowing
the proof to grow with the size of one
witness that's the that's the main thing
it matches yeah
the the CRS depends on I in fact it
encodile but it doesn't depend on x
it only depends on and you will talk
about how to build uh such SSS
I am going to talk about it
that you're just gonna like
a lot of times all I
uh extract all are you sorry for every
location no I don't actually need to
extract from every location the point is
that again right for soundness I only
care about the fact that you know if one
of the statements is false right I only
want to get a contradiction uh you know
for that I see right in summer we're
going to bootstrap on carrying that
they're all eventually or not no I don't
actually care about that okay open
prediction I only care about you know
showing that uh you know yeah one of the
statements is false that's good enough
right we are in the conjunction settings
so yeah it's not the or settings
so now let's talk about uh the Second
Step so let's imagine that we already
have snogs for batch NP okay and now
let's see how we can use snox for batch
NP to build uh snacks for p so again by
completeness I don't mean complete for
MP I really mean complete for
deterministic computations
okay so here also the idea is very very
simple so
let's just think of a deterministic
computation written down as follows so
all of these columns here are just the
states of the turing machine so we start
with some input and you know you
transition through all these states and
eventually you you stop right so I can
just rewrite this uh in the following
way I can write down capital T NP
statements where each statement simply
says that you know the transition from
the first day to the second state is
correct the transition from the second
state to the third state is correct and
so on
right
and now I can just try to you know
use a snack for batch and P to actually
build a snack for deterministic
computations so that's kind of the high
level blueprint but there are obviously
several uh issues that show up yeah like
why do car is like complete yeah so
again complete for deterministic
computations that's true for status a
slug for deterministic competition he
plays Stark for batches no I I sorry
what I mean yeah maybe I missed using
the word but what I mean is that snacks
for batch NP implies snacks for p yeah
okay so yeah so that's a that's a high
level blueprint but there are several uh
issues here which I'm going to just
mention but uh hide under the rug so the
first is that you know you can notice
that in general these statements
themselves are quite large right these
states they could be quite large and
therefore even the the batch NP
statements here can be quite large so we
can you know use cryptography to
actually shrink them so just think of
hashing and using appropriate hashing
there is a way to shrink all of these
statements in fact I don't even want to
communicate all of these statements to
the verifier right I'm I want to build
snot for P I can't compute the create
these statements
just this statement if
if you have snarks for batch and tea
then you have snarks for p of what size
uh good so here so if let's say I write
a t-time computation the snark for T
time computation will be roughly poly
log in T and then security parameter
okay unrelated to the space yeah exactly
so that's the point that I was actually
trying to uh that's before okay you're
saying before the obvious thing so to
speak would be space yes exactly yeah
exactly yeah so to get rid of the space
dependence we you know we can hash uh
these uh these states right and then I
don't even want to communicate all of
these T you know things to the verifier
so there's an additional animation
missing here imagine a hashing across
these teach statements as well to you
know some just one hashtag list okay so
so that way you know so again there is
some cryptography involved here which
allows us to shrink everything and uh
you hold these in peace
yeah I mean you can just think of you
know the uh the way they actually become
NP statements is you know the state
basically becomes a witness yeah once I
do the hashing the state actually
becomes the witness yeah
yeah
So eventually there's just going to be
one hash right and then you know the the
witness will be you know the state and
you know the imagine a path in the
Mercury or something like that what's
the key point that differentiate this
case
good yeah good so yeah so the second
thing that is missing I'll answer your
question in a second so the other thing
that is missing here is that in batch NP
right the T State means they don't have
any relationship to each other right
they are just T arbitrary statements
right and there's no requirement that
there is some consistency or some time
together of the statements but here we
do actually care about that right it's
important that this st2 is the same as
this st2 and st3 is the same as this one
here yeah so also also you are saying
that uh now the witness size for a
single statement is actually pretty
large but you are saying that uh if I
look at a statement then the size of the
proof is equal to the witness size of
one yeah so okay so now you're asking
great question which I did not want to
answer but yeah there is a way to deal
with that also in by shifting to the ram
model and you know we can all of these
things can be addressed yeah
foreign
that we need to make sure that these
statements are actually you know uh tied
together right so sd2 is the same as is
the same in both of these instances
right and so on so again for that also
uh we use cryptography and we use
hashing which allows us to you know do
this time together of the statements and
this is where uh you know Rachel your
question kind of uh shows up so this
does work for uh p in the sense that uh
you know we can ensure that this
consistency actually works across each
of these statements in the case of
deterministic computation there is an
efficient way to check this uh for uh
General NP you know this step just falls
apart
we don't know how to think of it as in
this way right what is happening here
when I try to tie these statements
together
you know prior to tying them together
all I have is sort of local sorry local
soundness right I'm saying okay this
step is sound separately this step is
sound separately and so on but there is
no notion of global soundness right and
that we this problem is is not unique to
this particular you know approach this
has shown up even in Prior works in the
setting of private verification and we
know how to solve this problem for uh
deterministic computations for but for
non-deterministic competitions the
stitching together of local soundness to
Global soundness just doesn't work
yeah so again I'm just saying that in
the case of B actually in the reduction
I can actually just check everything for
a long time you know it's a tea time
it's a polynomial time computation I can
just check everything yeah and otherwise
yeah that's the yeah so that's really
the the Crux of the issue again
technical barrier or fundamental value
yeah so then finally uh let's go to the
third step which is actually how to
build these uh somewhere statistically
sound interactive uh proofs for batch NP
so the construction that I'm going to
show you again skipping a lot of details
but the high level blueprint is very
similar to Killian's protocol for those
who are familiar with killings protocol
so the idea is as follows so I want the
proverb wants to prove key statements
right conjunction of these statements so
what he's going to do is write down a
PCP for each of the T statements okay so
pcps are written in this row wise
fashion and we have t rows
and now we are going to uh hash this
just remember is this the
State such so now I'm just talking about
batch NP so you can even forget that
that translation so you can just think
of them as general statements
[Music]
in the interactive setting good yeah
sorry I I forgot that transition yeah so
now that we have argued informally that
snacks for batch NP implies not for p
I'm now going back to batch NP and
focusing on you know how do we build
interactive proofs for batch NP with
this somewhere statistical soundness and
the right amount of compression right
right amount of succinctness so I'm just
focusing on that step right so you don't
need to think about how these statements
X I look like right
okay so again we have these T pcps and
we are going to Hash them in a
particular way so the hashing is going
to be actually column wise so for
example the first hash which is a small
digest is going to encode essentially
the first bit of all the tpcps
okay and similarly the second digest
encodes the second bit of all the pcps
and so on okay so roughly the number of
hash digits that I have is just
proportional to the size of one PCP and
this is communication I'm okay with for
now right
so this is going to be a special hash
but uh yeah I'll just mention briefly in
what way it is special
okay so the approver now sends all of
these digits to the verifier so the
verifier is now just as in Killian's
protocols and PCB queries and in fact
these queries are going to be the same
for all of these species
and now as a first step
the approver is just going to open these
columns
okay so forget about communication for
now let's just focus on uh soundness so
I want to achieve this notion of
somewhere statistical soundness
and for that what I want to do is ensure
that these hash digest so that three of
them can somehow together encode one
witness right some witness corresponding
to the ith statement and the way I will
do that is by using these uh the hash
function that I will use will have this
property that it can it can also be
programmed on an index I and now once I
program the hash key on index I it will
ensure that each of these digest encodes
you know the ith bit of the each hash
so by encoding the ith bit of each hash
or the input to each hash it ensures
that basically an entire PCP is encoded
we simply encodes the old column using
computationalize
[Music]
yeah so I'm encoding exactly just one of
the rows and this again
cache which again very similar notion to
or rather the motivation for some
statistical Founders so something about
the errors here
another thing is so I want to think
about it
um
people excited yeah so again exactly so
the first guy just started going back
right the first digest is encoding the
first bit of all the pcps the second
digest encoding the second bit of all
the pcps and so on and now the way I'm
going to do program one PCP in these
digest is by using a hash function where
you know once I program the key of the
hash on bit I what it means that in each
of these uh hashes right the ith bit of
the input is programmed it's
statistically binding on the ith of the
input right so the I bit of the input to
this hash is the first bit of the ispcp
right and similarly for this one also is
the sorry the uh
it's the it's the second bit of the if
PCP and so on right so this way I have
encoded the entire is PCP so can the
hash function just output the ISP and
ignore the the rest so that you are
going to the you know you're talking
about the construction of SSB hash I
mean you do need uh you know some
Collision
yes the program essentially just means
that the the key of the hash right it
can encode a bit I and uh you know and
this bit I the hash key hides the is bit
of the sorry this this bit I and the
idea is that once the key is programmed
or it encodes a bit I the the guarantee
is that you cannot produce two different
inputs let's say x and x Prime where
they differ in the IR bit but they have
the same hash awesome
thank you RIT statistical yeah that's
going to be statistical exactly
okay
so yeah so achieving somewhere
statistical soundness is uh easy you
know uh right once we use this template
so now let's talk about sorry yeah so
once we encode the uh the ith PCP then
you know we have statistical soundness
for uh for the location I so now let's
talk about communication and
verification time so so far I said that
you know in response to the PCB queries
the verif the approver just opens these
columns right but you know look at the
size of these columns right each column
is of size T So as such this proof is
not really the same so far right because
the opening is is too big right we want
to be sublinear in T
okay so let's just look at uh you know
these uh columns actually right so
essentially you know each of these
columns I can just think of what the
verify does here right it's basically
going to run the PCP verification uh for
the first PCB the second PCP and so on
right so I can just imagine you know
each of these verification steps as just
uh you know a new batch of NP statements
right and if I just imagine them as a
batch of new npe statements then I can
just try to you know run a batch NP
proof again that is instead of asking
the verifier to actually verify this I
will just ask the approver to give me a
new batch NP proof right and Records
right so that would be uh
no this these are just individual PCP
verifications right yeah that time
together we already did in the
transformation from batch NP to P here
we don't need to worry about it yeah
yeah good so yeah exactly so so the
problem is that yeah we started if you
think about this recursion right we
started with these statements but then
in this uh you know this delegation step
right I again have key statements right
so this recursion is not really
interesting yet right it will never end
I will always end up doing you know
batch MP40 statements so yeah so that's
not interesting so the key idea that uh
you know that that happens in these
Works to achieve as the thing with is a
folding step so the idea is that you
actually somehow fold two statements
into a single statement and this
basically allows you to compress T
statements in the recursion step to
basically T by two statements right and
if you can actually do this folding of
statements then you can now keep on
recursing right because after then log
steps you will end up with the you know
yeah
in the in in a case where you can just
send everything as it is right so this
folding uh of the statements it's not
something that we can do uh you know
trivially but what is shown in uh in
Prior works is that you can actually do
this folding of statements if the
statements have structured and in
general you can always use cryptography
to sort of in you know create the
structure
so just as a simple uh example if you
think of the statements as just like
literally just numbers right uh which
are let's say one two three four and so
on right to basically fold one and two I
can just use a number uh you know so so
sorry to fold two statements let's say
two I minus one and two I I can just use
the number I right and from from I you
can rederive to I minus 1 into I right
so it's a very trivial uh folding and
then there are additional steps which
again I'm not getting into in this talk
which are involved in making sure that
the verification time doesn't explode
but this is sort of the the key idea
which allows you to achieve compression
basically fold the statements into uh
you know T statements into T by two then
T by two into three by four and so on
until you know the prover can actually
send the proof in the clearance so are
these new statements
when you sum them up are they shorter
than the original one so yeah so the new
uh so when I go to T by two right I have
to ensure that each statement is
actually as big as a statement in the
key case right yeah I I don't just mean
literal concatenation otherwise yeah I'm
not going to achieve anything right so
yeah so that's why I was saying that
this folding the way I showed it in the
in the picture I mean here there is
really I'm just concatenated them but
actually what happens is that yeah you
compress them into yeah the witnesses to
be
shorter to the
so go back from it you have W to like go
one slide that there's a w one W two you
don't need them to be this length of
yeah so that so I mean that also happens
in the background but yeah I'm again
hiding uh yeah all of this information
but yeah that also happens yeah
of course so so the way it actually is
shown in the in these papers is that uh
so first you define like a very
particular uh language okay which we
call index batch index language so there
this kind of folding is is just there
the way the language is defined it is
literally the statements are just
numbers
and they're all connected to some hash
which is part of the NP relation circuit
right so their folding is kind of easy
the main uh difficult step is to ensure
that the verifies runtime doesn't
explode and then there is a general
transformation from this particular
language which has this very nice
structure for foldings to General uh
so it is General in that sense right
that basically you can first consider a
very particular language where the
statements are structured do build a
batch MP proof for that and then you do
a general transformation from that
language to General implement oh
this should be W4 oh yes yes
okay so this is uh sorry so so for this
interactive proofs do you need algebraic
assumptions or can you get away with
just uh so no not really uh I mean for
the O for this interactive groups yes we
are you because we are using this hash
functions uh SSB hash so there you will
end up using either things like lwi or
ddh but you know
we yeah we don't know it from General
assumptions uh but yeah all of the nice
assumptions that we care about yeah
[Music]
uh is the in the two to one folding is
it do you get statistical like is there
no so again the way I I displayed it on
the previous slide I it was a bit
misleading again we are not showing a
folding step for General uh languages we
first consider a particular language
where uh this folding is straightforward
and then once we build proofs for this
particular language then we do a general
transformation from snacks for batch NP
for a particular batch MP language to
snacks for General batch MP that
specific language is is the folding
statistical or is it yeah I mean there
the folding is
okay so a few notes on uh efficiency so
asymptotically these uh you know proofs
are great uh in fact uh I think we will
hear uh later in the in the workshop
even proofs that have uh that are super
small in the sense that there is not
even a multiplicative dependence on the
security parameter it's additive so rate
one uh proves
concrete concrete efficiency wise these
groups are not so great uh so there are
few uh annoying things that show up in
these construction this is also true for
the recent music instructions so first
of all the way we currently use CI hash
and the current constructions of CI hash
they induce non-blackbox use of crypto
and uh also in terms of the actual
underlying tools the crypto tools that
we use to build these objects are kind
of hell so
yeah but probably not a good good thing
to compare uh these proofs with the
Practical snack instructions that are
currently used in the real world
uh so one thing that I did not really
mention so far is that even though
almost all the works that I you know
that I presented in an earlier slide on
snarks focus on this feared Shamir and
correlation interactivity hash framework
there's one work which is an exception
which is a work of uh Waters and Wu uh
so they don't use Fiat Shamir no
correlation intractability no pcps they
build a batch uh proofs for batch NP
using bilinear maps and this is a very
uh you know uh particular Construction
in that it really uses bilinear maps in
a in a way that we don't know how to you
know instantiate from any other
assumptions this is sort of for those
who are familiar the ideas are similar
to uh the the non-interactive zero
knowledge proofs construction of growth
ostrowsky and sahai
I'm not sure if I understand well
defaulting but let me just ask if you
could have done three to one folding
then you would avoid it you would have
solved your problem without pcps and
recursion right you fall two to one if
you could have just followed the t21 you
would be done or is I'm not
understanding following correct oh so
that is just I mean you know like it's
unusual uh uh you're saying like why why
just two why not uh fold more things
your whole thing is starting with t and
compressing it to one right yes and
you're like well as a tool I'll just
easily trivially compress two to one why
don't you build a tree and trivially
compress T to one no but that is
actually actually what is happening
right it's just that we are doing it uh
you know level by level right so first
we fold T to t t by two right then you
know you delegate this to the work but
now the next time you you're 40 by two
to T by four alternating steps you do
the folding but that doesn't shrink the
with the overall witness length does not
yeah yeah
good
okay so yeah how many minutes I have
five six minutes or something that's
okay good yeah okay so
so let's talk a little bit about snots
for energy right so so far I only talked
about snots for p and some subclasses of
NP like batch and P so what do we know
in this regime in the context of
standard assumptions so first of all we
have this uh you know famous barrier to
building snacks for IP from General fix
which essentially says the following
so it says that if you want to try and
build a snark for NP where you want to
reduce the soundness of the snark to
some falsifiable assumption okay so
again by falsifiable I just mean that in
so this is the assumption
uh that the the Challenger in the
assumption is polynomial time okay so
this uh so generic says that this you
can't really do uh using reductions that
cannot decide the language
so it essentially says that you cannot
build snogs for NP
for snogs for any NP language L
using reductions uh where the reductions
just don't run in time that is
sufficient to decide the language itself
so this is again this is a simplified my
simplified view of uh Gentry Wix the I'm
not giving the formal statement here
right but this is the takeaway of gentry
Wix and for those who care there are
some details here so for example Gentry
Wix talks about adaptive soundness which
means that the statement and the proof
is chosen after looking at the CRS so
this this is an important detail but uh
you know I this is not the point that I
want to focus on
adapters so oh in a non-adaptive case uh
you know the statement is chosen before
this year foreign
Waters in 2013
which shows that you can actually build
snots for NP from IO from
indistinguishability obfuscation I won't
Define indistinguishability obfuscation
you will hear about it tomorrow uh I
think Rachel will talk about it
so
so yeah so there is a construction of
snacks for NP uh from
indistinguishability obfuscation so few
points so first to answer uh
um first to answer uh iftak's question
so this construction achieves
non-adaptive soundness right so the
statement is chosen before looking at
the CRS but more importantly in terms of
you know comparison with gender weights
this result as it is does not uh you
know say anything about Gentry Wix
because uh IO is not a falsifiable
assumption
okay but now of course you can say well
if I O is not a false durable assumption
I can just instantiate I O with the
latest and greatest results so in fact
this is what we can do so we can take
this construction
instantiate uh the i o in high waters
construction let's say with the with the
work of ayush Rachel and Amit and what
we get is this following picture right
so so I'm just you know instantiating
now I O from a bunch of uh you know
falsifiable assumptions
three or four assumptions right and now
I can just look at uh you know this this
this combined thing as just one
reduction right but what happens here is
that
um what you actually get is knocks for
uh this language L via a reduction uh R
Prime that actually decides the language
so remember gentrific said that you
can't actually build snox for MP okay
again adaptive non-adaptive soundness
aside you cannot build snacks for NP
using a reduction uh that cannot decide
the language and what's iwaters plus
yeah then Sahara shows is that you can
build snacks for NP right using a
reduction that actually decides the
language you say the language means the
language yes
okay thank you
if I consider you considering the start
exam is where the statement is thrown by
the cheating proverb yeah thank you
particular static soundness where I
consider sequence of false statements
and only prove the samples with respect
to that sequence then I always actually
know that was it not that it's actually
a falsifiable assumption
because you do know that for that
sequence of statement you are going
towards the owner
is because the reduction
which you don't know exactly I I really
just meant it that way right so when I
say IO is non-posit five but I just
meant that is in the definition right
the the Challenger doesn't know that the
circuit shows it by the adversary
whether that equivalent right so if I if
I focus on this notion of soundness
we're only looking at fixed statements
is actually
I will actually shows you you can build
it from free download time fossil file
consumption
of soundness it can actually prove the
sound is where the statement is chosen
by the approver because just by unknown
uniform security reduction if foreign
[Music]
if you do here right the the assumption
that you will end up using here will
actually be quite strong in the sense
that they will have to be uh strong
against due to the witness length
in essence the point that I was trying
to make here is that you know the the
core of uh gentrific's lower bound
letter Vector bound comes from the fact
that the soundness notion of snar right
is itself non-fault survival notion
right because the uh the Challenger
cannot figure out if the statement is
true or false right and that's kind of
what is crucially leveraged when you
build snack from i o you basically
transfer the non-falsifiability of the
soundness definition in snugs to
basically then the non-falsifiability of
i o definition and now eventually you
pay for it in the assumptions right when
you instantiate the i o construction you
eventually pay for that uh by using
assumptions that are quite strong the
interesting aspect though is that you
know one may think well why can't I then
just do it all the time by just using a
sufficiently strong assumptions right so
let me mention that point a second so
the bottom line you know combining all
of these points is that you can build
snots for NP from quite strong
assumptions right but with a large CRS
that grows with the witness size right
and this is the interesting thing about
the Arrow Construction that even though
you are using very strong assumptions
right you are not paying for that in the
size of the proof right usually when you
do because in order to use such a
functions you will be doing complexity
leveraging right and in intuitively we
should be paying for that in the proof
size but the the nice thing about this
construction you don't pay for it in the
proof size you pay for it only in the
CRS size
yeah and that's the the interesting
aspect of it and uh in some uh cases for
some languages we showed last year that
you can even shrink the the CRS size but
one point that I want to make is that so
far as so far as far as I know there is
no no no non-iowa approach to stocks for
M2 right this is essentially the only
approach we know and basically approved
techniques are quite Limited
uh
so not only the Infinity but some
interesting languages for which you can
do without I know maybe something else
so I mean you know again so
defining that interesting point that's
really the the question because again
for things like uh batch NP or even
bounded space NP we can do it from
standard assumptions without IO so
witness encryption is enough for
slightly Recreation of the
um
yeah my business encryption has the same
flavor as iOS right so don't have any
limits for adults
right yeah as far as I know there is no
we don't know of any any form of lower
bound right yeah this is where you know
both directions sort of failed in the
sense that the formal we don't have any
formal lower bounds but in terms of
actually trying to you know build snark
you know techniques wise we are limited
we don't know how to exploit the
non-adaptivity to actually build a city
foreign
yeah so you are saying that what if I
actually show that generates extend
gender mix to the non adaptive setting
so again I don't think so because uh you
know of the fact that Dio construction
this this you know the difference in the
reduction time right so there's Network
how many tools
these are all excellent questions uh I'm
happy to discuss them offline but yeah
yeah there are many things I I still
don't understand about this
okay so I think I'm out of time yeah so
yeah I'll just maybe mention with one
you know open problems that remaining
I'll leave but yeah uh you know in terms
of cryptographic proofs the the most
natural open questions uh you know
snacks for NP from standard assumptions
with small CRS so it would be nice if we
can build it from lwe right or some
other single assumption uh or even just
new techniques for proving soundness and
in terms of nizzix which is not
something I touched upon a lot uh we do
know now nizics from you know most of
the assumptions we care about like
specific assumptions like learning with
errors uh ddh all those sub-exponential
dth you know bilinear Maps uh you know
and and you know many many of the
assumptions we care about there are some
things still missing like for example
learning parity with noise and so on but
otherwise we do know it from uh most of
the assumptions we care about but we
don't know uh analytics for MP from
General assumptions besides the original
results on I don't know W or Triple E
whatever and I'll start door uh
permutations
um but for example we don't know nizzix
from any public encryptions right in
fact we don't even know whether nessics
really are in minicrypt or uh crypto
Mania you know but even this would be
nice too
I think I'll just leave it
[Applause]
however have a bridge